our fourth favorite game of 2015
God it was a game that had us pulling
our hair out but what a wonderful
experience to pull your hair at -
Michael Hardy blood-borne tell me about
that world
I love blood-borne so much there's so
much to say about the combat but I
really love the level design I mean I
can play for four hours one night and
not get to like a huge boss but at the
same time I'm still unlocking these
shortcuts that lead back to the lantern
so it's such like a foreboding world but
it's every time I kind of find one of
these new roots it's as much of victory
in itself just because I feel safer I'm
getting more mastery over this world and
it just overall it's such a great you
know punishment versus reward factor
yeah so dense like no fun at all in
terms of like the level structure it
just seemed like immaculately crafted
there's no fat on this game with almost
none it's so precise and everything and
it serves a purpose and Eric Air Force
to combat in that game strikes that
incredible balance of the souls games
did between being incredibly difficult
but also fair like when you died you
knew it was your own fault you just like
yeah I mean talk about precision you're
mastering the weapon that you like right
and there in this game there aren't as
many weapons as like a Dark Souls but
they have two forms so you can trick
your weapon you have your like
one-handed weapons your two-handed
weapons and you're trying to figure out
the best way to use them and on top of
that you're learning against the AI
right because the AI you're trying to
figure out their movesets so you can
stagger them backstab them and it's just
a beautiful thing when you learn their
tactics and then you can punish them and
you're like I got that sweet backside
beating a boss you I can jump up stand
up and stuff yes yeah it's a game yeah
you meet bosses that you think you never
there's no way I'm gonna be able to beat
this boss and then you do and you you
you've learned how to do it and it's
it's incredibly like just well
personally rewarding experience also
whether you can replay quite a lot like
you play with a different weapons on
you have these 10 weapons you kind of
find out which one you like the most you
play with that for a while and you're
like hey you know what if I tried this
other weapon and then you kind of find
out oh that kind of screws up my build a
little bit I might just have to make a
new character and go agility base and
then you're like I love this weapon too
like the chikage which is a like kind of
like a katana blade that I got later on
is just like this is great like I want
to play with this so then kind of end up
having another character and you just
keep playing the game like slightly
different because that's just how it is
and as you're playing the game you're
sort of unraveling this story that it's
not really a story in the traditional
sense of games like really explicitly
telling you stuff but you sort of
implicitly learn a lot of Beth this
universe just from being in it and
talking to people and experiencing its
rules yeah half the people you meet just
have these really subtle riddles that
they'll tell you and at this you want to
know more but at the same time it does
such a great job of kind of obfuscating
this huge world that you feel is there
just lurking under the surface and it
just adds to the really like horror tone
of the overall experience blood-borne
one of the best games to come out in
2015 as far as we're concerned and the
fourth best game to come out in 2015 and
also with the point out that it is a
heist exclusive that we have on our top
25 list so congratulations sony fanboys
that's one for you
you